pékin rio new york mais aussi londres et
très vite c'est au tour de paris et de
la france d'être touché le monde entier
frappé par une pandémie meurtrière
c'est le scénario catastrophe imaginé
par les autorités sanitaires mondiales
est décrit ici en 1995 il y à 25 ans
parmi les situations envisagées
l'apparition brutale d'un virus grippal
dévastateur dans de nombreuses villes de
la planète
un virus inconnu contre lesquels les
scientifiques seraient désarmés
voilà des années que le monde médical et
les autorités sanitaires s'attendent à
une vaste épidémie des années qu'il le
dise devant la caméra
à l'image du docteur if qu'aucun
toujours en 1995 un virus qui serait un
nouveau virus qui ne seraient pas
couverts par le vaccin qui apparaîtrait
de façon un peu explosives ou qui se
répandrait de façon un peu explosive en
pleine période hivernale est un problème
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
des propos qui prennent une résonance
prophétique aujourd'hui plusieurs
spécialistes ont alerté l'opinion
publique ces deux dernières décennies en
2002 l'épidémiologiste antoine flahault
évoqué une possible pandémie de grippe
on redoute on attend en redoutant une
grande pandémie est une épidémie qui
serait dû à une nouvelle souche de virus
dont on sait qu'elles devraient arriver
bientôt on ne sait pas exactement quand
2005-2006 et l'apparition de la grippe
aviaire qui décime les oiseaux par
millions et si la pandémie tant annoncé
c'était celle ci c'était la crainte de
nombreux spécialistes dont le virologue
bruno lina
aujourd'hui membre du conseil
scientifique le des pandémies il y en a
chaque siècle de trois et il n'y a
aucune raison pour que le 21e siècle
n'est pas une pandémie de grippe tant
qu'il y en as rhume moi je suis
incapable de vous dire aujourd'hui si le
h5n1 donnera une pandémie
il n'empêche que c'est le meilleur
candidat c'était la première fois que
les médias relayaient autant cette peur
d'une vaste épidémie qu'elle soit causée
par le h5n1 ou par un autre virus mortel
le fait qu'une épidémie surviennent et
probablement une grippe très grave est
quasiment une certitude ce qui est en
revanche moins certains c'est le moment
précis où ça va survenir
le président américain de l'époque
george bush sonne l alarme ce virus
pourrait provoquer la première pandémie
du 21ème siècle et nous ne devons pas
laisser cela se produire mais les
nations était elle prête à riposter
le professeur didier raoult actuellement
au coeur d'une polémique sur le
traitement contre le coronavirus affirmé
que non on pense que globalement notre
état préparation à une épidémie virale
et d'ailleurs on le voit chaque année au
cours de grippe est très mauvais
finalement la contamination humaine par
le h5n1 a été très rares le fléau a
annoncé ne s'est pas produit mais dans
un livre titre alarmant et alors que le
danger planait encore le pneumologue
jean philippe derenne demandé aux états
d'anticiper cette épidémie à venir
imaginez une guerre avec 200 millions de
morts c'est une guerre bactériologique
c'est une guerre bactériologique part
exactement 100 qu'il n'ya pas vilain
manipulateur qui fait du bioterrorisme
c'est une guerre qui risque d'arriver
tout seul la guerre est arrivée selon
ses mots récemment utilisé et malgré les
alertes de nombreuses voix s'élèvent
aujourd'hui pour dire que non nous
n'étions pas prêts
[Musique]